diálogo de paz retomado la guerrilla del
ejército de liberación nacional y el
estado colombiano oficializaron en
Caracas la vuelta a las negociaciones lo
hicieron con sus respectivas
delegaciones de parte del gobierno
colombiano el senador Iván cepedam
mostró optimismo hay un ambiente de
entusiasmo de diálogo constructivo en un
comunicado los garantes de las
negociaciones Cuba Noruega y Venezuela y
los invitados la Iglesia Católica
colombiana y la ONU también mostraron
esperanza en el proceso Venezuela además
será anfitrión para el diálogo el
presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro ha
reconocido el papel de Venezuela en La
Paz entre las FARC y el estado de 2016 y
además considera clave este país por la
presencia del Ln en el territorio
venezolano esto también lo piensa la ONU
que aunque no la considera una guerrilla
binacional aseguró que hay vínculos de
colaboración con el gobierno de Nicolás
maduro este lo niega también el de hecho
esta misión no ha podido entrar en
Venezuela ni tampoco entrevistar a
miembros de la guerrilla otro de los
motivos para establecer la sede en
Venezuela lo dio a Franz 24 la analista
internacional Mirna Jones la vuelta
internacional de Nicolás maduro la
entrada de Gustavo Petro pero también lo
que va a ser la futura ascenso de
Ignacio lulada Silva en el mes de enero
pueden dar un impulso a esa aparición
regional Venezuela haya sido clave
anteriormente para la paz en Colombia
además de acompañar en 2016 el proceso
con las Farc antes a principios de la
década de 2000 contó con el apoyo y
mediación de Hugo Chávez con la extinta
guerrilla y en 1990 el presidente Carlos
Andrés Pérez apoyó la desmovilización de
la guerrilla colombiana del m-19